I'm Michael, I work for
devised a company of Cesena where development
applications
not only but currently with via chain e
in this the twenty minutes I want to talk
of how to make de florio in
php application on google app engine
that what I wanted to do was create
an application was just the word l
and do a kitchen sink type thing
then a small china application
that he could have some things inside
a few examples to be able to show you
how it was actually done
php integration on google app
engine I thought then that the world
he absolutely needed one
tutu application because those facts
until now they didn't satisfy me
totally brackets how many must php
I thought less well ok all the code
is available to that tab account is
freely downloadable even now if
want
perfect so i left from
a tutu application that does not
nothing else after I will show you that
accept a file a description e
load everything and make the list said
duch has entered one so far
what is really interesting and we'll see
like what are the necessary exteriors
to be able to make it run on google
app engine very quick introduction su
what was with its features
main php on google app engine
first of all the php version
available in 4 recently 5 between
a lot of 56 will be released for 54
consider that most of them
applications run on 53 and some on 52
so much so
plus they vary in php turns in one
this sandbox means that it has
some features some
limitations such as particular from some
extensions not available in
cool detail that I believe is fine
an extension that more or less everyone is
expect to have in a draw in
php standard
the magic to work with my vehicles
then resize processing
image and another 15 was an ad
example the one to check i
processes then create super processes
hole that etc. of me
the ecdc are rigid there are yes yes yes ones
graph the question some functions are
disable some permanent mode
he quoted me some and it's that you can't
execute processes run at commands
from within php functions that
work with files in general that
create made frogs etc after we will see
because some are partially disabled
slash and pre grace type modification
and others are disabled soft mode
so it means that they can be
manually re-enabled
also here we will see later how it is possible
do it what is the particularity the file
system and read only
that is why it is not possible to go
to perform functions that work
with temporary files and so on
then your deputy code on a
file system that read only
so if you have apps that do
caching on file system or yes
expect to be predictable below
it can be as problematic as you need to be
rethink it so that it works the way
different files can be explored
on google plus store later I'll show you
like other particularities it is not possible
call external services directly
that's why curl is disabled on
google service called orf
service and even later I'll show you
how it is possible to implement
quite transparent integration
other features as he said before
in the cold
replies must be generated within
some time 60 seconds per issue
scalability efficiency and the
size of the answers generated
dynamically it must be the 32 best
of me
then the first experiment we have
you made a graph to the question you deserve one
handbag
the first experiment we did
when there is access to google app engine
has been install without sadly
we discovered that unfortunately symphony
it depends on its own level is needed
inside the kernel and other libraries
depends strictly on the fact of having
a filesystem that can be written to today
I can tell you it's not possible
installing symphony is possible
install sinex that we would like the relative
the small center child and we say so
yes here I made an example with twigg that
here too they have templating bridles
php vaguely marty relative intrigues ad
example you can disable the
caching so it is possible to say that not
go to write on file system are not
sincerely smarty in that case though
you could pre generate it before the fly
harlow after christmas integrates done in that
way there practically to see
after other things the sessions natively
are saved on the main cash e
therefore practically all the functions of
low level to work with
sessions session start scene id etcetera
they work as you would expect the play
which contains all session data from
great saw shaun this too
works quietly without
having to do nothing if you use a framework
you may need to change landers
that the framework sets and to use in
effects in cash other particularities i
logs are managed via syslog also here
natively php has a function for
write the log on exists
and depending on or less than yours
application that your vocation
face caching does you have to rethink
change this behavior because
as we said before the file system is not
writable end these were a lot
quickly the peculiarities of
I advise you to read the
documentation that is very comprehensive
very complete this case of doing
really a summary of the things that
at least in my experience I am
found to face another step like it
preliminary for you could try
the app install to the sdk there is there
the link and requirements
you must have installed python on
car because most of the
Turkish supplies python and you need to have
installed at 1 php cga this because
as I will show you later there is a
server needs to test and needs the
module via understand that you download everything
put it where you want to talk to him about
add this url all inclusive in
so that then leaders can go to
draw classes provided by the sdk
when you need to use another step
next in a similar way to that
alex explained first
to deplore an application you must
create an apm file in the root and del
project shows us
I think it says ok what you have to write
first setting the name of the project
this was self-generated kept it that way
the version as explained by Alfredo before
it is possible to define more than one version
they are questioned about his penance in
time php enough nothing else
always in the same file you must say in
which way you want to manage the rl's
your application in my case in the
case of this application or defined
cooney and her in particular I said
that the rls they are mapped to
directory I'll show you better later
web css and javascript and so
the web is mapped
js all the rest is thrown into index
which is basically the front roller
ok then the php file from which it comes to
which all requests arrive and then
he internally makes the of space towards
right action
as I said before there are some
functions that are soft and dictated
you can re-enable them in this way here
defined a php.ini file always in the
root and your project
and here you can through this directive
of the cipe which functions to rehabilitate well
as he explained to him in the cold but it is
You can test your code in
see if it actually works
without having to complain about app engine
first this way the server starts
of development that you must pass
of the php cgi executable which is what
in fact it will take care of breaking away from the
php code e
the directory that contains yours
project
and you may also want to apply a host
make the server start up yours
tests once you have done everything e
you want to upload your own
app on app engine you have this
command update directory contains e
this project will require the first one
once the username and password are
those with whom he lived and benji and then
proceed to make him weak
application
at that point the application as it did
see in the cold but will be available on
the name of the project draft point
up point spot
ok of the slides I wanted you to show
now a little bit of code then first
let's start with the application this mine
wonderful application so I can
say I have to do the shopping
I enclose the perfect shopping list for
added a line this and that file
I can that is listed and can
download it from here I can give of
erase that bastic entity really
innovative because you laugh sorry is not ok
i show some code this is
the e-mail I mentioned earlier
you see quite big and the character
I'll take it as a yes ok I added
a directive to escape some files
in particular
the logs that are saved locally
on the local machine once deputies
they are saved on sysload and not there
more
if these here accept this parameter
which he accepts
yes we say that to date the majority
of non-legacy application we are using
all the paradigm neither from controller
so actually a php file just that
it flies all the requests then
internally, however, if you want you can do it
then having it done yes yes certain
I'll show you the code is not there
nothing really formidable
I don't know how many of you know silex
lots of perfect okay silex is a
micro framework is basically gives me
the possibility of defining in a way
quite simple of the routes and the
options that you can do on those
routes to dese this saying that when
I post to flash news
I perform this function here ok knock down
simple is not rocket science
here he defined the home routes here
it is not a repository that for scarce tools
the new that creates a new elite tool
of the Italian and download then
the first thing I told you was the logs
normally the logo would be saved on
file
ok so the default would be saved
on file I have to use syslog in this case
I have defined two configuration files
a local that specifies how it is
involves local and one application
prod
and that is controlled by this
There are a thousand other ways
this is definitely not the best but
it was the fastest so I did so
practically when I'm in the local thing
I'm saying well first that the files
are loaded on file system that
the url to where I want to plodari file of
form that will allow me to file plodari
flash news
and that the files will be uploaded to
web upload directory
all end here
so let's say the place behaves
as I normally expect the remote
what happens instead I can of kos
use as I told you google cloud
google cloud storage storage gives you the
possibility to define budgets
so of hitters where you can go to
put in your files and how
you can log in as explained
first in the cold using sdk you can
go and say we create a
vrl to upload my files and go
was in this parameter here that
parameter will then be used to populate
the action field of the form
once the file is completed
and a post is made
then l that you specify then i am
telling me a url to upload the file
and then when you're done
make a post with the content with the
files and other data, if any, in the
mail to stage news
ok that works in two steps
I do there is the form does the summit at
werder allo rl created by these
bookstore and then the bookstores do it on purpose
to the news
so if you noticed here I didn't have to
change anything
that is me anyway saying me
appearance of the data imposed on the lorelle
slash new allow me to create a
new tool here also le files
file operations work the way
transparent nothing
thanks to the fact that
integration with a
cloud storage has implemented as one
stream x is indeed if we go to
see here i'm saying charge up gs
that google storage and the no of mine
then budget basically their own
of code I don't have to change anything
f this integration made at the level of
squeeze for the same passion
similarly it works for the
requests to external services
I don't know if you noticed it wasn't
certainly visible at most
here I show the time here not here
I created it
but it is loaded by recalling a
external service there had been its own
external service doing total scraping
however many worked or looking for a
service remains to have the time
seems the hardest thing in the world
how the code works I show
even here curl has disabled but
functions that work with the file
accept work also with streams
import it is possible to create a context
this way saying st http method e
get and here I could pass others
additional parameters such as headers
http with customer streaming contest
we are going to physically create the object
context we move to get file
conference which is therefore basic
simulating what it would do curious
making an http get request with those
parameters that we have passed
actually in my opinion a specific case
I'm doing a get so we could
put it to make a certain post if ok
so this and how it works
integration external services all
functions that work on files accept
it looks and you can work this way
in the same way all the functions that
work here file allow go to
read and refresh yourself on the gluck up
google cloud storage because that too
see a stream as last as
work with the database
I'll show you the class too
really interesting simply a
repository for now to draw object
of a certain type
here I do nothing but create a
pd oe object you can make queries e
that make me return smooth objects
even these normal php code between
quotes as the integration takes place
well in case of environment of this must
medical I create a normal connection
of bilocale my name in the db username
password
nothing else app engine instead
the part that interests us is this you
create one from google and the meter of
connection is this unique link
socket this string here where this
last piece is the name of the fresh is the
project name two points in the name of
database for the rest minus a database
and this I seem to be all without passing
also other users to foreigners
connection here from this pd or end
all the rest of a way
transparent